so I thought that this class would allow
me an opportunity to first off create
and some sort of application or products
that would be interesting and enjoyable
to make and more importantly have actual
impact it would be working with someone
and doing something that would directly
benefit them and a lot of them to
improve their daily lives in some way
and I think that gives it a lot more
meaning a lot more power and makes it a
lot more enjoyable of an experience to
create
um so I really wasn't entirely sure what
it all would entail initially I thought
that I knew we'd be working with a
client I knew we'd be creating a product
but I didn't realize all of the focus
that would be put on the looking at the
client the contextual analysis the
figuring out what it is that the client
can do wants to do is able to do and
there's a lot of focus on features other
than directly creating the piece of
assistive technology and I didn't expect
that that would be the case but I
realized it was critical that that was
there because they really make something
successful you have to understand all of
the context surrounding it and to do
something that is really useful you have
to know what it is that the client needs
that's applicable both an assistive
technology and just in an working toward
for any client so I came into this class
hoping that I would be able to work on a
project that actually had an impact
because a lot of most of the courses i
had taken at MIT they were a theoretical
and you just work on problem sets and
you hope to apply the things that you
learn after college and so the last
semester and the semester I've been
trying to find courses where I can
actually use those skills like
immediately and like I feel like
practicing those skills is actually
what's going to help me learn them
better and so learning through
experience and that's exactly what I got
out of the stuff i was able to apply the
web design skills that I learned and
also just like the design the whole
design process that we were told about
actually applying into this analogy
well I learned that there was always a
lot more than meets the eye I realized
that there's a lot of I was surprised
working with both our client with
hearing about the other clients in the
class how much they were able to do even
with given their disabilities they were
very well able to do quite a lot of
things that I wouldn't have expected
them to be able to and I realize that
you can't you have to really focus on
what their abilities are in what their
needs are and I think having a client
there in the first place gave us is
level of focus that is normally not
found in creating in our case a software
application we're looking at a
particular user and focusing on what one
particular person wants and that made it
a lot easier to know what direction to
take it rather than having some nebulous
group of our supposed users out there
that we didn't actually know her
interact with
put in a lot of time at the beginning to
understanding the context and the client
and the situation and it's really
tempting to jump right in and start
coding and we didn't do that and I'm
glad we didn't do that because we were
able to understand what it was we were
supposed to be doing and what direction
we needed to take so I think that's the
biggest piece of advice there is to not
start coding right away but make sure
you really understand what you're doing
so we went through a bunch of iterations
first we started off with original we
just discussed with our client what he
wanted what his needs were and then each
of us so we had four people in our group
and we've separated and came up with our
own ideas of what the client might want
and so we came up with paper prototypes
and then we brought these four versions
into the next meeting and discussed work
like our client told us what he liked
about them what did we didn't like about
them and so from that we collaborated
and put those four together into a final
paper prototype and then just kept
iterating from there going back to our
client asking what he liked about it
what he didn't like about it and then
once we had a pretty finalized version
of what we were hoping to get out of
this project we went into actually
starting to code and separating the task
everything
the most challenging aspect was probably
while going through all these iterations
and coding um I kind of want to say it
was the actual implementation so coming
up with the ideas and everything it was
great it was like a lot of creativity
and trying to fix these problems but
then actually going into the coding
portion was when we came into the bugs
of like like how do we actually
implement what we want out of our
project we know like that we want this
certain type of screen there we know how
we want the user to interact with this
but how do we actually do this
technically and that was one of the
challenging parts of the class
I think the blog's were really a time
for reflection and thinking about what
it was we were doing I use the blogs at
least is sort of a way to catalyze my
analysis of the subjects and the
material presented in class and the
things we've been working on so I took
it and really look to analyze some
thought I'd have been having trying to
figure out how to think about one on how
to make computers more accessible and
ways in which that is sort of
fundamental in a lot of the architecture
and how it makes it difficult to do that
we're just analyzing different ways in
which we're able to allow people with
disabilities to be more integrated into
society and how society has to
potentially change their viewpoints a
little bit to allow that happen to a
greater degree
the most engaging asset was definitely
working with all of the people in the
course so my like three other team
members and our client which like I said
if you don't entirely get in other
courses and this one's you're sitting
down with the person who is going to be
using the product and that is really
that was the most engaging because I
knew it was gonna be fruitful and I knew
something was going to come out at the
end
I mean as far as like an education
perspective at least on this i found
this is of course where I was motivated
to do the best I could not by getting a
good grade or even as much about
learning something as it was about I
really wanted to help the client and I
think it's a client-centered focus of
the course that really drives it and
that is the I feel the most important
aspect because when you're working with
someone one-on-one they're relying on
you to create something that you know
it's going to help them you are really
well motivated to do the best you can on
that product and I think that making
sure that that emphasis is retained and
is the most important thing to keep
everyone really engaged in and to get
the best quality of products that is
possible from a class like this and
that's really the best way to make it
happen in my perspective
you're creating a product for your
client but you're also learning more
about a certain person's lifestyle and
so make sure to go beyond what you're
making as a product but get to know your
client as a person and that's definitely
going to be even more fruitful because
then you're not just focused on this one
like product product product but you're
learning more of how does this one
person have to live with their
disabilities and how can you integrate
like so many other things in your
environment to work help them and these
times with people like outside of the
semester